m
mais c'est un trait de lumière s'il vous
plaît
quand vous voulez
comment définir la mémoire
que nous le voulions ou non que nous
sachions non nous sommes responsables de
ce qu'ils nous unir à demain si mal
[Musique]
nous sommes fait de ce qui nous a
précédés vos papiers et pour partie nous
engageons l'avenir
vrai magasin
il supporte pas ce petit rat par exemple
comment ne pas être conscients de la
nécessité de nous unir pour nous épauler
les uns les autres et résister ainsi
[Musique]
quant au retour du totalitarisme
il faut rester ensemble rien ne doit
nous séparer
bien
c'est plus la passion y revit
[Musique]
l'espoir je félicite madame veil pour
son élection c'est en europe que je le
place
l'europe qui a surmonté la haine et la
barbarie votre travail madame fait la
vocation
ce n'est pas un travail c'est une
vocation le fait de mettre le bordel
faut partir chérèque
vous ne faites pas pas
avec
j'avais ton âge
tous les jours je vois mon nom
et
mon modèle
tous mes combats c'était
correr
[Musique]